hello and welcome to an intro to
self-driving cars my name is Jane
suffered and I'm the head of Lum that I
here at Udacity today we're exploring
the world of self-driving cars you've
probably heard of them
might have seen one or two and maybe
even had the chance to ride in one but
do you really understand how
self-driving cars work well you're about
to find out today we welcome David
silver product leader Udacity
self-driving car nano degree programs
David will explain how self-driving cars
work and share his insights into how
these amazing vehicles will change our
world
and then he'll explore some of the jobs
available to self-driving car engineers
please welcome David silver here in
California I'm really excited to share
with you both how self-driving cars work
and what's going on with them in the
ecosystem in the wider transportation
ecosystem and what jobs you might be
able to get working on autonomous
vehicles we'll start by just telling you
a little bit about Who I am so my name
is David silver I lead the self-driving
car team there at Udacity I've been at
Udacity for about two years I came here
to build the self-driving car program I
came to NASA T from Ford Motor Company
where I was on their autonomous vehicle
team in Palo Alto California and before
forward I was for many years a normal
Silicon Valley web software engineer I
don't know if any of you know what this
red icon here on the slide is but that's
Ruby I was a Ruby on Rails engineer
that's a particular programming language
and framework that's popular for web
applications in the few years ago I got
really excited about self-driving cars
but I didn't have any background in
automotive software or robotics so I
started taking classes online about
perception and machine learning and
system software and eventually I was
able to get that job or through non
autonomous vehicles at Ford and and the
folks at Udacity asked if I would come
here and build out for other people
essentially what I had done for myself
up half-two working on autonomous
vehicles so it's been a terrific ride
and we've had over 12,000
take our self-driving car and we program
and I'll tell you a little bit about how
self-driving cars work and in what the
nanodegree program covers first one
other thing I should mention about
Udacity is Udacity was founded by a man
named Sebastian Thrun Sebastian was a
professor at Stanford University for
many years he led the Stanford
University team that won the DARPA Grand
Challenge big hundred-mile self-driving
car race to the California desert in
2005 and they Google hired him to launch
the Google self-driving car project now
known as lame-o he was in Google for
many years working on that and
eventually Sebastian wanted to get back
to education so he launched Udacity so
Sebastian is a really interesting person
for me to be able to work with these
kind of the father of the self-driving
car and it's a real honor to get to
build out the nanodegree program with
him so you're you're learning from from
some of the best experts in the world
about how self-driving cars work so so
at Udacity we have our own self-driving
car her name is Carla and the final
project of the nanodegree program is in
fact that students get to put on their
own software on Udacity z-- real
self-driving car and drive it around a
test track a lot of california-irvine
and so it's really kind of about what we
think it wasn't only at Udacity
experience that the other program you
actually need to put your code on a real
self-driving car no matter where we're
students are in the world whether
they're in the US or China or Europe or
India or South America or the Middle
East or anywhere else you get to work
with a team of students from all over
the world and and then put your vote on
our car and it's a really neat
experience so let's dive into how
self-driving cars work I think of
self-driving cars as having five key
components computer vision and sensor
fusion which are how the vehicle
understands the world localization which
is how the vehicle figures out where it
is in the world planning which is how
the vehicle decides to navigate the
world that's really
the brains of the car what decisions
does the car make about how to move
through the world and then finally
control which is how the vehicle
actually turns the steering wheel and
it's the Prado and gets the brake in
order to follow the trajectory that it
came up with during the planning phase
and so we'll go through each of these
components through the lens of the
projects that students do as part of the
nanodegree program to give you a sense
of of how self-driving cars work so
we'll start with computer vision so I
don't know how well this video will come
across over webinar it might be a little
copy but this is a video of Carla our
self-driving car driving down highway
280 in California and Silicon Valley and
what we do is we give the raw video feed
to students and then this is one of the
projects that one of our students came
up with the two things are going on here
one the student is using computer vision
to find the lane lines and secondly
they're using this particular student is
using the neural network to draw those
bounding boxes around the other vehicles
on the road and so you can see a couple
of vehicles into the scene and the
neural network is trying to figure out
is those two vehicles is it one vehicle
eventually they separate figures out
it's two different vehicles and the lane
lines hold really steady even when the
road is curving and the pavement changes
color I mean this is really impressive
it's really pretty similar to what you
might see on an actual you know level 2
driver assistance system on the market
today and this is what students do just
within the first few months of starting
the Nano
program it was really kind of amazing
what you can do with computer vision
really really quickly there are a lot of
great tools out there and that's part of
what we teach is part of a nano degree
program so computer vision is really how
cars work with cameras to understand
what the world looks like that
understanding of the world gets
augmented with other sensors in
particular lidar which is is a term for
an array of lasers and radar are both
really important sensors to also
understand what the world what the world
looks like and and offset some of the
difficulties or the weaknesses of
camelina some cameras in particular are
not great at estimating things like
distance or speed or height so so if you
uh if you
can see this video now this is a video
of Carla driving down El Camino Real
which is the main commercial street
through Silicon Valley and this is
actually some work that our team did
getting Carla to the point where she
could drive on public roads he fastened
his license operate Carla on public
roads in autonomous mode in California
and you can see the camera feed here on
the right the camera feed is mainly
looking for stoplights and and
determining whether the light is red or
green and stopping the red lights and
then you can see this big black screen
here on the left and what you can see
are these red concentric circles and
that's the lidar scan as as cars as
other cars on the road that's our car
you can see these kind of blue
rectangles forming and that's the radar
feedback the feedback from the radar
letting us know that other vehicles are
on the road so what the lidar is doing
is it's using the red scan to match up
to this white map you can see these kind
of white pixels from the map that has
already been created so the lidar were
really using for localization which
we'll talk about in a second the camera
were really using here for traffic
lights I mean then the radar we're using
to detect other obstacles on the road
particularly other vehicles and and
that's kind of an interesting
juxtaposition of how all these sensors
work together you can use sensors for
all sorts of different things you can
use cameras for obstacle detection and
lidar as well but radar works really
really well for absolute perfection
lidar is super important for
localization and cameras are really
important for these like classification
determining what color and traffic light
is or whether a vehicle is a truck or a
car and bicycle or something else
so next Center vision how we use all
that sensor data together and when we
combine sensor fusion and computer
vision we get this really great picture
of how the world looks once we know what
the world looks like now we need to
figure out where we are in that world
and that's localization so um so
localization is is the the process of
using landmarks that dumb that we know
about to to triangulate our own position
in the world can have a little bit of
trouble getting that this video to play
well when the video plays what you can
see is
this is one of the simulators that we
build out for our students in the
nanodegree program and they have this
blue car that's traveling around and the
car is measuring its distance from
various landmarks those are those green
lines and as the car travels around it
finds different landmarks and it
measures its distance from them and it
essentially does a really complex form
of triangulation using a technique
called a particle filter in order to
figure out precisely where it is in the
world you might think we could use GPS
for this and GPS can be helpful but GPS
often has some pretty big inaccuracies
it's accurate to maybe about one to two
meters sometimes worse in in urban
environments where they're really tall
buildings that block the signal and so
having a high-definition nap and sensors
that can match up what the vehicle sees
nearby to the map and and match precise
distances allows us to do this type of
triangulation that determines exactly
where the vehicle is
um the next step once we know what the
world around us looks like and where we
are in that world the next step is to
plan a path through the world and this
is a planning so this is another one of
the project students doing the manatee
program this uses our highway simulator
that we built here at Udacity and you
can see this black car traveling through
traffic on the highway and you can see
these green dots that stretch out in
front of the vehicle and those green
dots represent the vehicles trajectory
that students are building as part of
this project is they're figuring out how
to navigate through traffic while
adhering to speed limits and
acceleration limits and jerk limits and
laying out these little pearl bowls
they're actually called waypoints that
the car needs to drive through and
that's how the car figures out how to
move through the world and it uses this
technique of first predicting where
other vehicles are going to be in the
future and then deciding what maneuver
but the car wants to take in order to
navigate around these vehicles so does
the car want to stay in its lane should
it shippings right for the tip lanes
last shut it speed ups and it slowed
down and then finally once the car is
determined what maneuver to take I mean
actually builds out this trajectory of
waypoints in order to UM to move through
the world so that's planning so once we
plan the trajectory
the world the final step is executed
control and control is how we actually
turn the steering wheel and hit the
throttle and hit the brake to move the
vehicle through the world and what you
can see here is one of our controller
projects this is a different simulator
Udacity built and this is one of our
students who is trying to program a
controller to follow the yellow line you
can kind of make out this yellow line
that's the ideal trajectory the goal
target trajectory that the vehicle
supposed to follow the green line is the
trajectory that that the controller
predicts it's going to follow based on
the steering angle and acceleration and
and brake that's being applied so using
those control inputs the goal is to get
the green line to overlap with the
yellow line as closely as possible and
in fact you can see the green line
overlaps with yellow I'm really really
tightly here which is an indication of a
really good controller that's following
the trajectory leave it alone so that's
how self-driving cars work first we use
sensors computer vision sensor fusion to
understand what the world around us
looks like next we figure out where we
are in that world with the help of
localization algorithms in a map um then
we plan a path through the world to get
to where we want to go subject to
various constraints like speed limits
and traffic signals and then finally we
use a controller to actually execute
that trajectory through the world and
get us on where we want to go using
steering acceleration and brake so at a
high level that that's what self-driving
cars are and the entire nano degree
program is kind of built to follow this
pipeline so so now that you understand a
little bit about how self-driving cars
work I'd like to talk a little bit about
the different jobs that exist in the
autonomous vehicle world the automotive
supply chain is this kind of very
complex ecosystem I mean it's getting
even more complex as self-driving cars
change the way that that automotive
companies relate to each other so um so
kind of at the center of the automotive
supply chain you can think of om OM
stands for original equipment
manufacturer you might also just call
these automotive
Hatcher's these are the brands that you
recognize probably from driving around
so Toyota and mercedes-benz Ford Tata
from India these are companies that that
sell cars they make cars and sell cars
but actually a lot of the work these
poems are doing these manufacturers are
doing essentially the work they're not
essentially but a lot of the work
they're doing is um pulling together
parts that different component suppliers
so there is a giant network of what are
called Tier one automotive suppliers and
their entire job these Tier one
suppliers is to build parts for the OEMs
so these are companies like Denso in
Japan Continental in Germany Delphi in
the United States
Bharat Forge is a one in India in these
companies their whole job is to build
different components that have been
pulled together to make the part in
downstream from the Tier one do you have
even another layer of suppliers called
the tier twos and these are much more
specialized suppliers they're often
companies that supply many different
industries not just the automotive
industry so if you think of Nvidia for
example this is also a great partner in
our nanodegree program Nvidia produces
graphics graphics chips GPUs that are
essential for lots of different
industries from gaming for artificial
intelligence but also for automotive and
so they supply often Tier one suppliers
are occasionally directly OMS but the
the Tier one suppliers will then
packaged up in Nvidia chip say into an
automotive grey computational union that
can survive the rigors of existing
automobile and then that Tier one will
will sell the solution on to the to the
automotive manufacturer and all of these
are companies that you might want to
work in if you um if you are interested
in self-driving cars in vidya does a ton
of work in artificial intelligence and
autonomous vehicles Bella dine is one of
the premier providers of lidar units
arrays of lasers that are used for
autonomous vehicles you might recognize
this here as the end right auto logo
they do a lot of work obviously both in
self-driving cars but also just
automotive
generally the entertainment consoles in
the center of a lot of vehicles Bose is
a tier 2 supplier doing a lot of work
mainly in town systems so that's kind of
the traditional automotive supply chain
OMS purchased in pure ones tier ones
participant your tunes
but as self-driving cars change on the
transportation world we're seeing new
companies can enter the picture so one
example our technology company so Wayman
Oh Apple Samsung acteve which spun out
of Delphi all our different technology
companies that are focused on largely on
the software behind autonomous vehicles
and these companies that traditionally
not been super engaged in the automotive
world but they are now spending lots and
lots of money and employing lots of
Engineers to build self-driving cars or
economy's vehicle software or economists
related technologies and then of course
even beyond the technology companies you
have the ride-sharing companies I mean
so these are companies like uber and
lyft and TV and Ola exam for India TV
from China these are companies that
right now are operating largely with
human drivers these networks of rides
and vehicles that you can fly down from
your phone on but all of them are
looking into autonomous vehicle
technology some of them like uber and
lyft and DDR investing very very heavily
in building self-driving cars and so
this is another type of company that you
might be interested in if you were to
work on autonomous vehicles so that's a
lot of different parts of the automotive
supply chain but you can think of it as
this very rich ecosystem with lots and
lots of different companies that you
might want to work for everything from
the brand name on emotive manufacturers
to the different suppliers who supply
the automotive manufacturers to some of
the technology companies that work in
the States to the to the ride-sharing
companies there are a lot of different
options so the last thing I'd like to
close with are just what are some of the
business models that are present in
autonomous vehicles because we can
obviously think of self-driving cars but
in fact there are lots of other types of
vehicles and business models that that
come into play and it's really exciting
to think about how the world might
change and what opportunities might open
up with autonomous vehicles
so so the first business model is kind
of the most traditional it's it's
selling cars so this is a Tesla Model S
cuter Tesla is currently selling level
two autonomous vehicles level two is a
terminology for driver assistance so the
driver can't just let the car drive but
but Tesla does a lot with their
autopilot feature to make driving the
car much more automated and and the
driver in many cases just has to deal
work and take over when the vehicle
isn't able to handle a situation more
important to our discussion here maybe
is the fact that Tesla is selling cars
directly to consumers and in fact this
may be a really important business model
for self-driving car companies and the
future is is just building self-driving
cars and selling them to people the same
way we build regular cars today or
companies build regular cars insulting
to customers today another business
model are is ride sharing so we talked
about that a moment ago allies a ride
sharing company in India in the u.s. we
have uber and lyft in China as d-v in
Southeast Asia there's crab there are
lots of different ride-sharing companies
and all of them are interested in
economies vehicles and many other
companies outside of ride-sharing like
lame-o like some of the automotive
manufacturers are also interested in
building ride-sharing networks so that
you can just hail a self-driving car
from your app maybe a car that you don't
yourself own um it will come pick you up
it'll take you somewhere it will drop
you off and then it will drive off and
pick up the next person all without a
human driver involved and you won't own
a car you'll just subscribe to that
network those vehicles so that's another
business model a really important
business model that sometimes gets a
little bit over what just talking so
this is a company called embark actually
but raised a big round of funding from
Sequoia Capital One at the top venture
capitalists in Silicon Valley autonomous
trucking um could really change the face
of logistics and how we move goods from
one place to another in a transition
goods more
from rail or from rail to a more on
truck based environment on it allow on
trucks to maybe drive in 24 hours a day
we may see on trucks driving
autonomously on highways kind of hub to
hub because highways are relatively well
structured and a little bit easier to
drive autonomously so you may have clubs
where that are right next to highways
where self-driving trucks
load up they get on the highway they
drive for hours and hours and hours they
get off the highway at some other hub
they unload and then maybe a human
driver takes the goods the last mile to
a you know to the customers house or to
the to the retail store that may be kind
of an intermediate step while we work on
on fully autonomous vehicles but
self-driving trucks are a potential
game-changer for I think the entire
economy a someone cuter type of vehicle
is this vehicle this is starship
technologies this is an economist
delivery vehicle on this vehicle is
designed to do something like what bring
you your lunch maybe you might order one
from you know a restaurant three blocks
away they'll they'll call you know one
of these little robots
it'll drive up the restaurant will load
up your lunch the robot will drive your
lunch to you and you'll pick your lunch
out and then the robot will la will just
continue on and it'll all happen on the
sidewalks at relatively low speeds so
this is kind of I think a creative
example of the way autonomous vehicles
might change might change our world a
different type of autonomous vehicle
technology is warehouse technology so
these are Amazon robots and Amazon is
already using robots to move goods
around in their warehouses um it's a you
can see these giant shelves of goods
they're actually mobile because they
have these little robots underneath them
that they drive under lift up the
shelves and move them around wherever is
the most efficient place for them to be
at the two different warehouse
technologies automated forklifts other
autonomous vehicles within within
warehouses that can eat up logistics
indoors and inside a facility
another type of autonomous vehicle is is
mining this mining is an environment
where where there are a lot of safety
issues a lot of health hazard issues but
the environment is really well contained
and so they're actually autonomous
vehicles already operating in a lot of
Mines driving these fixed routes back
and forth from maybe in one part of the
mind to another delivering goods in the
mind and and it's really easy for them
to do because you just kind of nap one
route and the car just kind of drives
back and forth or that the mining truck
drives back and forth through the mine
and another similar type of autonomous
vehicle is farming so by some measures
um there are more autonomous farm
vehicles in the world than in the other
type of vehicle this is a company called
Mahindra in India but John Deere in the
u.s. also working on farming similar to
mining vehicles you can program tractors
to kind of drive routes up and down
fields and you don't have to worry about
some of the path planning perception
problems that maybe you have to worry
about in urban driving it's a pretty
simple procedure but it can really make
farms much much more efficient and save
farmers a lot of money and time and then
allow them to I to take care of ever
larger areas and can grow more food so
these are just some of the different
ways that that autonomous vehicles might
change the world and in I suspect we
will see so many more business models
I think self-driving cars will change
the world in ways we can't even imagine
it's really really exciting it's an
amazing field to be in
the technology is so much fun to work
with it's so natural to be able to build
a program that drives a real vehicle and
sees the world in ways similar to the
way you and I as humans can see it it's
just really a delight and an exciting
place to be working right now so so
that's uh that self-driving cars I'm an
introduction to both how they work and
what jobs are available and then how
they might change the world and in
different ways and which self-driving
cars are going to market so I'll kind of
turn things off there I'll um I'll take
the presentation over to my colleague
Jane I think we have some questions from
students that we can answer and then
maybe some live questions as well
we do indeed thank you David um we
shouldn't be surprised to think that an
outstanding self-driving car engineer
like you can so elegantly lay out a
roadmap about the technologies and the
industry ecosphere so thank you that was
super enlightening I'll dive right in
we've got lots of questions already that
we collected both before the and during
now so let's jump into some technology
questions you named maybe some of the
most critical technologies that enabled
us to actually launch self-driving cars
and take them from theory into into
reality yes yes so two of the most
untalented areas right now three I would
say our perception localization and
planning I mean those are all things
that we talked a little bit about in
those slides I mentioned so perceptions
how do you perceive the world that used
to be really the hardest part
self-driving cars but the advances in
neural networks particularly a type of
deep neural network called a
convolutional neural network that works
really well with camera data and
starting to work with with lidar data
that's made perception it's helped us
make great strides in perception and so
that is no longer the blocker it used to
be although there's still a lot of
interesting things going on in that area
planning is is probably the most
difficult area of autonomous vehicles
right now particularly for urban driving
how do you make decisions about whether
to shift claims or even predict what
other objects in the world are going to
do so you know how to avoid them and
then localization is this very tough
problem because we're still very
dependent on these high definition
lidar maps that you need in order to
localize yourself to the world and those
maps are really expensive to keep up to
date because utility companies and
departments of Transportation
governments are constantly tearing up
the roads laying powerlines repaving
them and so it's really expensive to
keep those maps up to date and figuring
out a way that we can localize ourselves
in the world without a map is really
really important awesome
so you talked about lidar and I know
this is an intro um conversation here
but we've got some viewers who know a
little bit about self-driving cars I
think already because they'd like to
know if you could talk a little bit and
touch on the differences between some of
the sensing technologies like 3d lidar
2d solid-state spinning
my goodness lots of Decatur lighter so
so lidar is a really technology that has
been around for quite a while but is
really only picking up now or within the
last few years because of its importance
to autonomous vehicles and it's
traditionally been this very expensive
technology partly because they're very
low production runs there just wasn't a
lot of demand for lidar units and so the
by anyone lidar unit was a pretty
expensive process
now self-driving car companies are
buying wide our units in fairly large
numbers and you can see even greater
demand on the horizon and so costs are
coming down quite a bit and and that's
really been one of the main obstacles to
light ours so far has been just the
really expensive nature of them in terms
of the different types of lidar that are
available there solid-state lidar which
is kind of the most advanced form of
lidar that's currently on the market
even it is just coming on to market
versus the spinning lidar so spinning
lidar is though I know that literally
rotates around an axis and the beam just
kind of scans 360 degrees around the
vehicle and of course you can imagine
when you're spinning something with ball
bearings around an axis that that
creates all sorts of mechanical
difficulties and noise in the in the
signal and so what we'd like what
everyone would like to move to is a
solid state solution where you have use
kind of projecting out in lots of
different directions and and those types
of lighters are just coming online now
there's also something interesting work
being done in thermal camera imaging
that has some of the benefits of lidar
but also some of the benefits of of
cameras on so lidar in particular is
really really good at measuring
distances it works really really well at
night thermal cameras work really really
well at night cameras very good very
high resolution very good at classifying
what types of things our radar very good
at measuring speed so each sensor has
kind of its different strengths and
weaknesses awesome so long as were deep
diving into the technologies here to
what extent would you say that deep
reinforcement learning is being used in
both the production of in the
programming of self-driving cars yeah
questions so deep reinforcement learning
is this special type of deep learning
that plays out over a much longer period
so it's a you often play it like a game
and in fact deep reinforcement learning
has been really successful in training
agents to play games like chess and
though the alphago agent trained by a
company called deep mind which is part
of Google now has made some really
amazing strides in this area for for
self-driven cards deep reinforcement
learning has not yet proven to be that
significant although a lot of people
think that make change in the future and
there are really two big reasons for
that um one reason is that deep
reinforcement learning is very hard to
get to work and even in simulation
companies are having a lot of difficulty
getting deep reinforcement learning to
work for cars off I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a second and then the
second reason is even if you can get
deep reinforcement learning to work in
simulation porting that to the real
world becomes a really difficult
challenge so the reason you would want
to start in simulation is the way deep
reinforcement learning works is you play
out these long sequences where you make
a decision and then you see how that
decision plays out over time and if it
plays out well then you try and keep
making more decisions like like that
initial decision you made it for play so
poorly then then you start making those
kinds of decisions until you do that a
lot in simulation then eventually
hopefully in court or that trained
agents of the real world
the problem is I kind of glossed over a
lot of the difficulties when I said if
something plays out well or plays out
poorly defining exactly what it means to
play out well or play out poorly and in
a driving environment is is a little bit
difficult deep reinforcement learning is
notorious for the the challenges
involved in in building the scoring or
reward functions and you can design a
scoring function that you think makes
sense and then all of a sudden the deep
reinforcement learning agent kind of
optimizes for this really weird scenario
to get the best score possible and you
don't wind up with a great driver you
wind up with the driver that kind of
drives in circles or just hits the
brakes and stays still because that way
it won't crash and so figuring out how
to train that age and even in simulation
speaking of challenges have you talked
about some of the ways that self-driving
cars actually work with the planning and
logistics um let's go back to the
controller aspect
are there specific types of controllers
and algorithms that are best suited
towards self-driving cars and what are
they yeah control is this very deep feel
that is the deepest of all the fields in
autonomous vehicles because it's been
important for automobiles for decades
maybe even a century no much longer than
some of these other areas like
perception or localization so so the
most basic type of controllers a PID
controller a proportional integral
derivative controller that's a
controller that every mechanical
engineer would learn and you know as
they learn to become a mechanical
engineer and that is in fact the
controller that is used in a lot of
applications today including some
vehicles PID control has this
disadvantage though in that it does not
model the vehicle you should take the
nanodegree to learn exactly you know
what that means but essentially a PID
controller is figuring out if you
deviate too far from the goal trajectory
to steer back towards the trajectory and
that's fine it well but you don't really
have a model for how the vehicle does
that you simply say a friend further
away go back but you don't have this
idea of what you know what will the
vehicle do if I turn the steering wheel
this far to the left or this far to the
right and there are more advanced types
of controllers for example the one your
quadratic regulator in the model
predictive controller that actually have
models of the vehicle and allow you as a
control engineer to be more precise
about about how to steer the vehicle or
accelerate or decelerate the vehicle in
order to get to that reference to get
through really really smoothly and so
lqr an MPC linear quadratic regulator
and model predictive control are two of
the most commonly used controllers for
autonomous vehicles but there are all
sorts of different control algorithms
people invent their own control
algorithms and there are other types of
shape up type controllers that that that
engineers can use to give an autonomous
vehicle to follow a reference to
so when we're talking about like
detecting all of these things with
controllers think of the example when
I'm driving and I approach a crosswalk I
can kind of look to the faces of the
drivers or the pedestrians and get a
sense of whether they will cross or they
won't cross these are traditionally
really difficult things for machines to
do so how do you tackle those challenges
yeah that's a that's a great question um
that's more in the realm of of
perception so perception and then
prediction so kind of touching on two
different but very related topics and
the first thing probably to do is to
perceive what what is around you what
these objects are I mean it's amazing
how good some companies have gotten at
perceiving precise perceiving precisely
what something is so we know if you look
at some of the vehicles or some of the
videos they put out they seem to be able
to predict like the age of somebody you
know at the crosswalk and what gender
they are and you they haven't published
a lot about this but presumably they're
you patient to then predict like how
quickly will they move are they likely
to wait or to proceed through the
crosswalk
you know it used to be the case that we
would just kind of predict is this a
human or a bicycle and even that is a
hard enough prediction to make but when
you can get to the point where you can
actually not create but perceive
someone's age or gender then you make
even better predictions about them once
you've perceived what that thing is then
then you have a model hopefully you have
a model for how that thing will move
through the world so a vehicle you know
is probably going to follow traffic laws
destiny it may be less likely to follow
traffic laws but actually you can also
move in any any direction whereas the
vehicle is generally confined to
basically forward and backwards with a
little bit of steering angle so you have
different models for how these vehicles
might behave or objects might behave in
the world so yeah these two to connect
the problem perception perceiving what
something is and then prediction
predicting how it will move to the world
so a lot of that is based also out of
the sensors and what the you know what
you detect to perceive it so given that
sensors inevitably have noise built-in
how do you determine what their ground
to that ground truth is when you're
training the Algar
that's in building these bottles yeah so
um so ground truthing data is is in fact
one of the the more mundane but super
difficult tasks of building self-driving
cars so typically you know what you
might do is you might go out and record
a lot of sensor data you might just kind
of human go out with a car fully loaded
with sensors and the human will drive
around and then the sensors will just
record all this data and that's great
then you have a ton of data but what you
need to do next typically is to label
that data and and somebody needs to
actually look at at you know a camera
image and say this is a pedestrian and
draw a box around the pedestrian and say
this is you know a bicycle in that way
you can feed that label data that ground
truth data into machine learning
algorithm which will then you'll learn
from from the ground truth labels
essentially learn from the human label
the data on how to recognize different
types of objects pedestrians bicycles
props cards and there are whole
companies in there's an industry of
companies that that basically takes data
and labels it with ground truth
measurements once you have those trained
models as you mentioned there is all
sorts of noise and uncertainty in the
world in in perfect conditions um you
know when it's really bright out and the
camera is getting you know a clear line
of sight to UM to whatever vehicle it's
looking at then you might be able to
feed that data into a model and over
time if the model sees enough images of
what it thinks is the same person
standing at the same corner it will be
able to understand with increasing
certainty on what that person is
although or what that object is although
it will often express that perception in
terms of certainty so it will say I'm
you know I'm 92 percent certain this is
a person and five percent certain it's a
dog and you know one percent certain
it's a bicycle or something like that
and then it will make predictions based
on you know maybe for all three of those
different objects if it's a dog what
will it do if it's a bicycle what will
do and it will come up with several
different
directions about what that object is
likely to do often depending on what
that object is it's a person or a
bicycle and so you'll the prediction
module will have these different
trajectories that that object might take
in the future and you track those over
time and hopefully converge on on a more
and more certain on prediction of what
the vehicles going to do but you're
dealing with all these different
scenarios and that's part of what makes
autonomous vehicle so difficult is if
you think about all these objects in the
world and then predicting with various
levels of certainty what they each might
do in the future you get this very dense
branching of different possibilities and
so at some point you kind of have to cut
that off and make a decision frankly
also the hardest part about driving
figure out what the next driver will do
right so it's speaking of challenges
what would you say the most challenging
area is right now for self-driving
technology at this point in time and how
long do you think it will be before we
have cars on the street and just a
normal more populated way yeah um well
the most challenging area right now is
probably planning we talked a little bit
before about you know the difficulties
in perception and planning and
localization and and each of the ways in
which those is difficult perception is
traditionally been very hard but but
we've gotten better with the help of
deep neural networks planning is this
really difficult area because of all
those those branches that we were just
talking about in localization is a
challenge because of napping and how
hard it is an apps up to date in terms
of how soon we will start to to see
autonomous vehicles on the road um I
really think of it as a wear problem
more than a win problem so there are
self-driving cars on the road today in a
lot of different places if you go to say
Mountain View California where Udacity
headquarters is you'll see lots of of
Wemo self-driving vehicles driving
around because we actually are just
about a half mile from their
headquarters could you go to Arizona way
mo among other companies is doing a lot
of self-driving car testing with with
real passengers if you go to Las Vegas
you or I or anybody actually at least
allegedly I have not yet done this
can hail an autonomous vehicle there is
a self-driving shovel there sponsored by
triple-a and built by a company called a
BIA as well as lyft is running some
self-driving cars with safety drivers in
Las Vegas Boston has done a lot of
self-driving car tests because of some
MIT spin-out that that are located in
that area Pittsburgh similarly with
Carnegie Mellon spinouts internationally
um China has several cities where
self-driving cars are in tests right now
Singapore has had a lot of self-driving
cars we're starting to see them a little
bit in London in some places in Germany
Jaguar Land Rover in in Europe
mercedes-benz so you're starting to see
them in a lots of different places and
then the question is how quickly will
cars um will these do fences expand you
know so instead of being just in
downtown Las Vegas or downtown Phoenix
how long will it be until you can drive
between Las Vegas and Phoenix a in the
self-driving car and then the other
question is how quickly will companies
start to pull the safety driver Wemo has
said they'll they'll both start
accepting the general public in their
vehicles and without a safety driver by
the end of this year so it may be that
by December you or I could catch a plane
to Phoenix and ride in a lame-o
self-driving vehicle around around
suburban Phoenix maybe we should do that
should we do that absolutely I mean
count me in so it's more and more of
these cars are on the road it's hard to
ignore the question of ethics and
decision so the philosophical trolley
problem aside how do you think ethical
decision making gets integrated into the
algorithm so self-driving cars in a
responsible way that's a great question
and it's one that self-driving car
engineers have have been able to get
away without thinking of ton about for a
while because the problem has so far has
largely been just how do we get the cars
to work as opposed to how do we make
particularly difficult decisions I think
I think it probably helps to talk a
little bit about the technology of how
these decisions get made they typically
get me using something called a cost
function so as a car or self-driving car
is considering various options that it
might take whether it should speed up or
slow down or turn right or ship planes
left it will often project seven
steps out into the future several
seconds out into the future you know
what might happen what are other
vehicles likely to do what are other
pedestrians likely to do what decisions
am I like is the self-driving car likely
to have to make in the future and it
will work those decisions backward and
calculate a cost for each of these
different options so you know what's the
cost if I turn left what's the cost if I
speed up what's the cost by coming to a
complete stop and then it will try and
choose the lowest cost option and so
when we start to think about ethical
decisions what we really need to do is
figure out how to program these cost
functions so if I as a self-driving car
drive up to a stopped car that's broken
down and blocking the road what is the
cost for me of slowly easing that around
that car going into the wrong lane
passing the car and then getting back
into my lane it was that such a high
cost maneuver than I'm better to stay in
stop and waiting for the tow truck to
come and and remove that car that's
blocking the road or is that a high cost
procedure but it's lower cost than
sitting here for three hours while the
tow truck comes and so so I should you
know move out around that around that
stock car and proceed on my journey so
figuring out exactly how to program
those costs will be
I think ago she ation between automotive
engineers automotive business people and
government regulators and I think
automotive companies have generally been
really responsible about this nobody
wants to be unethical in these types of
decisions nobody it wants to put anybody
else at risk but there there is some
reliance on on the general public me the
acting cool governmental entities I'm
providing some guidance as to what you
should do in complex scenarios that will
help us program these cost functions
better yeah so we've heard about the you
know one-off accidents and those of
course get a lot of attention to
questions about that one how safe do you
think self-driving cars are for the
general public in who takes the
liability in the event of a crash or a
system failure
yeah so I think a few things about
safety they all kind of touch on those
questions um I think one is just to
highlight what a tragedy it is when
anybody dies and
automatic it is for particularly for
people working in this industry I mean
that is one of the really tough things
about the autonomous vehicle industry is
is unlike you know in web software this
is an industry that really has a lot to
do with physical safety and then people
can get hurt and nobody in the industry
wants that to happen and it's really
traumatic and in a real tragedy most
especially for the the victim in the
that the person involved in the
collision and and their family but but
also somewhat for the people working in
the industry another thing to think
about is is just how kind of tragically
common automotive fatalities aren't
there about 30 the last year there about
37,000 automotive fatalities in the
United States about a 1 and a quarter
million worldwide more actually for the
first time in about a decade at least in
the u.s. seeing an uptick in automotive
how these people think because of
distracted driving with cellphones
although people aren't sure yet and so
that's just a tremendous number of
people who are dying over a million
people around the world every year in
automotive collisions and so the hope is
that self-driving cars can become much
safer and saves people's lives and and
bring back not bring back but but
prevent some of those tragedies in terms
of who takes the liability in these
scenarios right now it tends to be the
company that is developing the the
software that that is running the
vehicle so you know some companies are
developing entire vehicles other
companies are developing software you
know they're purchasing vehicles and
then putting their own software on it
typically if you're running the software
on a vehicle at the moment you're kind
of in control of the vehicle and so that
tends to be the entity that's most
legally liable I think over time what
we'll see is a pretty robust insurance
industry grow up around economists
vehicles it's a real this whole
transformation from voting the car to to
self-driving cars is a real disruption
in the automotive insurance industry in
terms of of you know instead of having
retail customers maybe buying insurance
policies it may be the big companies
that are producing self-driving
ours are buying much bigger insurance
policies to cover themselves as a
company yeah so um I'd like to pivot if
we can now from our discussion of the
technologies behind this to talk a
little bit about careers in a
self-driving car industry so can you
tell us a little bit about how you broke
into the self-driving car industry yes
so I mentioned in the slides that I was
a normal Silicon Valley web software
engineer for about ten years actually
programming in Ruby on Rails and a few
years ago I got really excited about
self-driving cars but I didn't have any
background in an automotive software or
robotics so I started looking around for
any class I could take online that was
related to autonomous vehicles and then
I started applying to every job I could
find and this was I guess now about
three years ago so it was uh
the industry has grown a lot it was a
much smaller industry back then and I
applied for lots of jobs and lots of
companies were not interested in talking
to me because I didn't have a
traditional automotive background or I
didn't have a PhD in in robotics but but
I got interviews of some companies and
fortunately the folks at Ford said you
know there's there's really no reason we
should hire you you have no background
in this area but you do seem really kind
of weirdly excited about self-driving
cars and they said so you know would you
take a contract job and and at that
point my wife was seven months pregnant
and they said well you take this
three-month contract and like if it
works out maybe we'll offer you a
full-time job and and I said yes I said
absolutely like whatever I can do to
work on autonomous vehicles I was so
excited to work on this stuff and I just
I felt like if I could get my foot in
the door it would work out
and so I joined the team at Ford and
things went really well there I loved
for it was such a great company to work
for they they have some of the smartest
people I've met working on autonomous
vehicles and that led to to them
you know offering for me that join Ford
permanently and that led to sebastian
recruiting me the udacity to to build
the nanodegree program and here at
Udacity I've gotten the the pleasure and
privilege of working with some of the
best autonomous vehicle engineers from
places like mercedes-benz and Nvidia and
uber and BMW and lyft and all the
different companies that we partner with
the Udacity so it's been a really
terrific experience into the economy's
vehicle industry I mean that's awesome
instead of in addition to saying yes to
things that might not be your best like
what's your home your best outcome might
be in an interview do you have any
specific tips for someone who's
interviewing for a job trying to break
into this field for ways to get noticed
and stand out amongst the crowd and get
hired
yes yes so um so I think in autonomous
vehicles it helps to have both breadth
and depth and that's probably true of
almost any job that you might be looking
for and so understanding how autonomous
vehicles work in the end I think is a
real advantage the self-driving car
nanodegree is a great way to do that but
you can do that other ways to cobble
together you know online courses or just
read a lot about self-driving cars watch
a lot of webinars like this and then
being able to really have a passion and
an excitement or a certain area of the
autonomous vehicle stack and have done a
lot of projects in that area is another
advantage and that's one reason why it's
part of the nanodegree program in fact
we have students do a whole bunch of
projects now in our six-month nano
degree program we have nine different
projects that students do in different
parts of the stack and going even deeper
than that and building your own project
so maybe driving down the road maybe
have a friend drive and you hold up your
camera and record a video just like I
kind of showed the video of Carla our
car driving down the highway you could
record that for yourself or a student
but someone interested in the industry
could and then build your own neural
network to detect vehicles or find lane
lines build your own mini self-driving
car there are tips you can build now or
you can buy now online that will help
you build a mini self-driving car and
then you can train a neural network or
use other techniques to get it to say
follow a line of tape around the room
there are a lots of different projects
like that they're publicly available
academic datasets you can download and
do interesting
with lidar data radar data camera data I
think finding that area you're really
excited about will really help you stand
out and help hiring managers know where
to put you and where you're interested
in being that said you also kind of have
to be willing I think it helps to be
willing to say yes
to wherever you should go so for example
when I went to Ford they said what do
you want to do and I said I really want
to be a perception engineer I want to
work on deep neural networks for
self-driving cars and they said that's
great but where we really need help
right now is on our computational
hardware team and I say great I'm happy
to work on that too whatever
I didn't say whatever but I said I'm
thrilled to work on on computational
hardware I mean I was I was so excited
to get that opportunity and so I think
you know having an area you're
passionate about is really really
important but then also being open to
opportunities when they present
themselves even if they're not exactly
what you plan for yourself I think is
also also really important that's
awesome it's hard it's hard not to
appreciate your enthusiasm for this
field still now which is wonderful
so you talked about the nanodegree
program two questions one what are the
prerequisites for someone who might not
have experience in self-driving cars or
even you know artificial intelligence or
neural networks um before they take the
nanodegree program what would you what
should they know and what you expect
that they know and what is the main goal
in the nanodegree program like what does
someone leave with yes
so we actually have two different nano
degree programs in this space so I'll
talk about each of them
one is our intro to self-driving cars
program and the other is our
self-driving car engineer program the
self-driving car engineer program is a
more advanced program that's designed to
take a student who already has
programming experience in a basic
engineering background and train them to
become an autonomous vehicle engineer by
walking through the different areas of
the the self-driving car stack some of
the ones I showed in my slide deck plus
some other areas in building up those
types of projects where you're doing
things like finding lane lines or
building a path planner to navigate
through a highway traffic and the end
goal is that you have as a student this
great portfolio of projects that you can
take to an employer and and show that
you've you've done all these different
things across the self-written car stack
and maybe even gone
four deep in one or two areas that
you're really excited about and going
beyond the minimum project requirements
and built a really terrific project in a
certain area then the prerequisites for
the self-driving car engineer program
are intermediate level programming
ability ideally in Python or C++ since
those are the two languages of the
automotive industry or the autonomous
vehicle industry Python more for machine
learning than C++ more for system
software and code that goes on the
vehicle and then basic physics basic
linear algebra basic calculus basic
statistics so so things like
trigonometry kind of come back to haunt
software engineers like me who kind of
forgot about them in high school some of
the mechanical engineers who are already
in the automotive industry and looking
to learn more about autonomous vehicles
they know all about trigonometry and
physics and mechanics linear algebra you
know something that is a software
engineer I've used off and on but
something that sometimes mechanical
engineers or other types of engineers
aren't as familiar with and if you're
not familiar with any of those areas we
have our intricate self-driving cars
program which is a shorter program it's
only four months compared to the six
months for the full self driving car
engineer program the intro to
self-driving cars program is designed to
Train anybody up in those prerequisite
areas in Python and C++ programming in
calculus linear algebra statistics
physics all those different areas of
core engineering and software
programming that you need in order to
become a self-driving car engineer you
can start with intro to self-driving
cars anybody is is is eligible to start
that program and then once you graduate
that program you'll know everything that
you need to know in order to jump into
the self-driving car engineer in a
medical program that's awesome so one of
our viewers has asked are there any
hardware projects integrated into the
self-driving car nanodegree program yes
so we have a1 hardware project you could
call it a hardware project arguably that
I mentioned at the very beginning the
presentation that I never got back to I
apologize I should have highlighted that
more fully which is putting code on par
with our self-driving car so the very
final project of the sulfur
you are engineered nanodegree program is
is putting code on Karla students form
teams of about five students eat with
other students it can be students all
around the world you can find students
that are just in your country or
timezone and you write code that goes on
Karla to drive parlor around a test
track on our test lot and then use the
actual camera in Karla to detect the
traffic light classify the traffic light
stop when the lights red go when it's
green and it's kind of amazing you kind
of start with that in simulation then
once you get everything to work in the
simulator you send your code to us here
in California we run it on our simulator
just to make extra sure everything works
and then once everything works we we put
it on the vehicle and we send you a
playback of how your code runs on the
vehicle and if it you know needs a
little bit of tweaking you can tweak it
send it back to us we'll run it again on
the car once a month actually this
Friday is one of those days we invite
anybody in the area to come to our test
slot and if they want to see their code
run on the car and do some debugging
live with the vehicle they're welcome to
do that so that's um that's kind of the
main hardware project in the nanodegree
program we have other neighbor to do
programs that Udacity most notably our
robotics offerings in your nano degree
program where you can actually buy a
system on a chip so in that particular
program robotics you just got to buy an
Nvidia Jetson tx2 system and you can buy
that and train neural networks to do
robotics types of projects on that on
that system and the self-driving car
program were mostly operating in
simulation and in development on your
local machine or in the cloud but then
you actually get to put code on hardware
at the very end and I catch so much I
remember meeting the team that want the
competition for the very first and it
was amazing because they first of all
they were from all different parts of
the world it was the first time they
actually met themselves it met each
other in person and then they actually
got to saw their see their code run on
Karla so it's it's an incredible program
to work remotely with people around the
world on an actual car that's running on
an actual track so it's it's incredible
we only have three more minutes left so
I wanted to touch on something I think
which is important is what is the value
of the
degree in the eyes of the hiring
managers and the partners that you see
and if you can share with us some of
your success stories what what if some
of the students done in what kinds of
jobs have they gone on to accept yes
this is one of the things I think we're
really really proud about of the
nanodegree program is that almost every
employer that we know now is familiar
with the nanodegree program this is I
think considered like the kind of most
common and probably the best way to
learn about self-driving cars now and if
you take your resume to companies and
say I completed the Udacity self-driving
car engineer nano degree program that
really means something
employers have an understanding of the
the breadth of topics that that you
cover in the number of projects that
students have done as part of the
nanodegree program and so so we're
really excited about that and and it's
been really helpful to students as they
apply for jobs in the industry we have a
lot of different success stories we have
students who work at almost every
self-driving car company you can imagine
we also have a lot of students who come
from those companies and you know they
may already even be working on
self-driving cars but but they say you
know I'm working on one particular area
I know a lot about say localization but
I'd love to learn more about perception
or control
and so that's why I'm taking the
nanodegree program so we have for
example I'm George Sung was one of our
very first students and one of the I
believe the very first class of
graduates of the self-driving car
program and before he even graduated he
landed a job at BMW he had been an
engineer at a chip manufacturer just
working on on building faster
computational tips and then he got a job
largely through the nanodegree program
and also his own efforts at job hunting
and interviewing he said he did he
applied to 90 jobs but he got a job at
the MW working on their deep learning
team he's been there for about a year we
have a number of students have been
hired on to the deep learning and
autonomous vehicle teams at Nvidia has
been a great
of ours we have students who work at
automotive suppliers like like Delphi
and active and continental we have
students who work at manufacturers like
mercedes-benz and Volvo a number of our
students have been hired onto the
autonomous vehicle team a lift who's
been a great partner of ours for the
intro to self-driving cars nanodegree
program working on everything from
perception to localization we have we
had a path planning challenge with Bosch
who's one of the biggest automotive
suppliers in the world actually D
largest automotive supplier in the world
a seventh Germany and a number of our
students work at Bosch on planning and
on another on other teams there so we
have we have students all over the place
and we're really really excited about
the contribution of our students to the
autonomous vehicle world and and their
ability to then hire more community
students because they understand as well
the value of the education we got
through the nanodegree program and
they're really excited about hiring more
students awesome Steven thank you for
all our help we're out of time I wish we
had more time because we have a ton more
questions people are interested in open
source projects they can contribute to
in books that they can so maybe we can
follow up with some resources and
follow-up emails we send to give people
some ideas on where they can look for
these things but thank you so much for
all of this enlightening information
thanks to all of you who joined in with
us today this is one in a series of
webinars that we do on professional
development check the links for some
upcoming webinars that we have on other
topics and David thank you for spending
this hour with us teaching us about the
technology the career opportunities in
just the field of self-driving cars if
any of you are interested in learning
more about Udacity self-driving car nano
degree programs that David talked about
today check the link in the chat and
we're out of time and overtime so stay
curious keep learning and see you all
next time thanks David
bye-bye